election 2013 what does the Left Party
want in the interview Left Party leading
candidate Zara VAR can connect the world
of seeing social protests the euro
crisis is dividing society yet your
party which emphasizes social justice
isn't benefiting why is that we're
polling at a steady seven to nine
percent that's not bad for a long time
there was no left-wing in Germany with
that kind of support but that's still
not good enough I think the basic
problem is that many people don't think
their voice makes much of a difference
so they might stay home and of course
we're also suffering because the SPD the
major opposition party hasn't come up
with a candidate who's a real threat to
Chancellor Merkel that means there's no
serious chance of building a left-wing
government no one expects pêche
Steinberg to do anything differently
from miracle and that's her guarantee of
staying in office got on t for this
concept are other parties taking away
your big issues the Christian Democrats
are gaining on social justice the new
rightist AFD party is anti euro are they
poaching from you they're not because
they're not credible when you see
miracle discovering the idea of rent
control after she's been in power for
years and has done nothing to stop the
explosion of housing prices it's nothing
more than a campaign joke people can see
right through that
no but that's condyloid to go to a show
and bus via didn't mention what all you
have to make clearer to people is how
important it will be to have a strong
left opposition in the Bundestag whoever
ends up in government I think it'll be a
grand coalition that will decide if
those in power will dump the costs of
the euro crisis on to regular folks of a
god veterans it's opposite r1 will be
costing their clears off decline Lloyd
the up so very busy cannot there's not
much you can change in the opposition
but you guess you'll be there because
the SPD doesn't want to work with you
mccartey mixes I'm Oliver I'm what the
Stein look made that clear that means
the SPD doesn't take its own election
promises seriously if they did they'd
have to rule out a coalition with the
FDP because that party is against the
minimum wage we can't have a coalition
with the CDU because they're against
regulating banks then they'd have to say
they'd consider governing with the Left
Party but they're not saying so the
signal they're sending is we've got this
great left-wing platform but the SPD
zone candidate doesn't take it seriously
the other than because it's in fuzzy
food and what's the first thing you
would change we'd fight to change the
labor market put an end to the
scandalous conditions were seeing people
slaving away for just 5 or 6 euros an
hour people working full-time and still
having to go to unemployment offices and
collect welfare we want to outlaw the
subcontracting of labour we want a ban
employers from stringing workers along
with one short-term contract after
another and ensure proper working
conditions for people then there are
pensions it's intolerable that people
who've worked hard their whole lives
even average earners can't live on their
state pensions we want to keep the
retirement age at 65 and make sure that
people can retire with a secure standard
of living of course it takes me money to
make all that possible so we say have
millionaires and multimillionaires pay
wealth taxes we have such an
unbelievable concentration of wealth in
Germany and at the same time we have
poverty in the public sector we have
municipal governments on emergency
budgets we've tossed out lots of money
to save the banks and meanwhile there's
not enough money for health services or
for equipping hospitals even feared food
is untied steam stuff an audit starting
from car noise on but Germany is
collecting more taxes than ever before
the state has money
why tax hikes
that's a fairy tale as a share of GDP we
don't have more tax revenue of course
every year the figure is higher because
our money is also worthless factoring in
the big tax breaks for the rich in
recent years there's actually a drop in
tax revenue we do have high tax revenues
from excise duties for instance middle
income earners bear a huge share of
taxes that's another thing we want to
change we want to give relief to people
making six thousand euros a month or
less but when people are raking in
millions we think the state could tax
them more and what's really important is
fighting tax evasion these days were
seeing corporations paying just 10% in
tax while millionaires and billionaires
watch their fortunes grow in tax havens
and effectively don't pay any tax story
apologies me if I'm moving from there
and unless in fact just kind of story on
side who would pay wealth tax people
with life savings of a hundred or a
hundred and fifty thousand euros think
they bleed no absolutely not
we say that in our election program and
we stand behind it it would start at 1
million euros in private wealth and 5
million in net business assets companies
debts would be factored in people this
wealthy should do their part for the
good of the community it shouldn't be
the low income workers getting bled with
excise duties sales tax energy tax and
so on I think that's an unfair tax
burden does finish on fire sure I'll
fight along destroyer off comes what can
you do to help create new jobs everyone
we want jobs but more importantly we
want good jobs the government is so
proud of its alleged jobs miracle but
their miracle means more and more people
forced to work several part-time jobs
and the creation of more low-wage
part-time jobs we want to promote steady
full-time jobs that means stemming this
whole sector making it illegal we want a
minimum wage of 10 euros an hour it's a
matter of human dignity mid mentioned
vote it's a torn hardest how does that
create jobs
Albert Schweitzer
we'll create jobs if people earn more
when wages rise people's buying power
Rises - the German economy is so
concentrated on promoting export we've
got export surpluses but there's a
little domestic demand
that's because pensions are a disaster
and wages have been shrinking for over
10 years can Germany's 80 million people
really close that trade gap against
billions of consumers worldwide we don't
have to stop exporting but a completely
one-sided concentration on export means
that suppliers trying to sell here in
Germany need domestic demand craftsmen
need demand here in Germany construction
companies don't export their goods it's
important for them that towns have the
money to fix their streets that ordinary
citizens have the money and the
stability to build homes these
investments this demand can only be
created right here at home over the past
years it's been neglected it's an
absolute for not least one consumer your
party says it doesn't want to get rid of
the euro but you've said quote the euro
is impoverishing entire countries and
that's fueling hatred among the people
so what is then your policy what's this
thing it's unequally ticket yeah I
promise to double our election program
clearly states we're not the ones who
want to get rid of the euro
it's those in power who are destroying
its foundations the euro has a future
only if economic inequality is solved
when we see what's happening in Europe
what some countries were a quarter of
the people are jobless where over 60% of
youth have no chance of employment these
are conditions comparable to the Great
Depression we say it's a scandal how
much money is being spent yet again to
rescue banks across Europe yet
apparently there's no money to boost
investment in Greece companies in Spain
and Ireland can't get loans because
banks won't give them any this is no way
to help these countries back on their
feet
if Berlin's policies don't change if we
in Germany don't see higher wages then
we'll end up splitting Europe and
destroying the euro many economists
accept the golden rule that wages should
be tied to productivity the country
that's veered away from that the most is
Germany where we've seen wages drop over
the years while unions have fought for
increases in other countries and I got a
chemist our budget Germany's economy is
the strongest in Europe not exactly
Germany has been more competitive than
other countries because of dropping
wages but in terms of people's own
prosperity we haven't made any progress
instead we have a shrinking middle class
we have lots of people who are much
worse off than before it's not all about
abstract economic data here we should
also look at life expectancy and birth
rates in those terms Germany's not doing
too well in Europe Francis the leader
how unified is your party really
you've got politicians who are part of
the radical left in West Germany and
communists from the former East is that
an issue if there's not improbably in
cuisine as a naturalist in Vienna part
time we are a party with different
traditions everyone knows that of course
we have differing views on some things
but I think our last party conference
showed clearly that we have plenty of
common ground we passed our election
platform almost unanimously it has the
issues we all want to fight for that's
why the Left Party was founded it wasn't
founded for us to argue with each other
unfortunately in the last few years we
did argue too much but now the Left
Party has stabilized and we stand
together that means during the campaign
and afterward as a force for social
change in this country that's really
subsonic often decent lunch overton your
partner is another prominent Left Party
politician Oskar LaFontaine are you like
the Kirchner's in Argentina or the
Clintons one of you picks up where the
other stops or do you argue at the
kitchen table
to get into a function tightens down on
current issue as of tonight it's not
that one of us is quitting and the
others starting I've been in politics
for 20 years and I've held political
office for many years we agree on many
things and see some differently
it's exciting to exchange and discuss
ideas but we don't just talk politics
that would be pretty sad we have other
things in common - I'm no concealer and
league of minds on the team you don't
like it you're known as the glamorous
face of the left party that could have
advantages you're famous get interviewed
in women's magazines why doesn't your
party use that instead they put you in
with seven other candidates maybe we
have so many good people that we
couldn't choose just one others might
see that differently I think all of us
are putting up a good campaign and I
hope we win over many voters
multi-dimension about soy Ben thanks for
talking to us